little late coop and we had a flag to  Indian surveillance drone solar sails  power an entire farm to do Murph I knew  nothing  Murphy's Law  you're a well-educated man coupe a  trained pilot and an engineer the world  doesn't need any more engineers  we didn't run out of planes and  television set we ran out of food  dad why did you need me after something  that's bad oh we didn't Murphy's Law  Murphy's Law to me there's something bad  why  it means that whatever can happen will  happen  we must confront the reality that  nothing in our solar system can help us  they need to tell me as you plan to save  the world  we're not meant to save the world  we're meant to leave it  and this is the mission Boober train for  I've got kids professor get out there  and saved them  not knowing when you're coming back  we must reach far beyond our life spells  we must think not as individuals  but as species  we must confront the reality of  interstellar travel  I love you forever  I'm coming back